à seulement 15 ans arthur est déjà un
chef de projet qui n'hésite pas à
prendre la parole pour défendre son
travail
puis tous les groupes qui ne participait
pas à la finale nous ont gentiment prêté
leur leurs éléments du décor avec ses
camarades de 3e b il présente le robot
qu'il élabore depuis plusieurs mois sa
classe participe cette année au
challenge robotique un concours
départemental dédié à la programmation
l'addition évidemment on rentre sur une
sur quelque chose qui est relativement
simplifiée par rapport aux enjeux de la
robotique
mais je pense que l'idée ce site inspiré
ces élèves là peut-être se piquer leur
curiosité et si c'est un sujet qui leur
plaît qu'ils puissent eux approfondir
mieux comprendre thématique de cette
troisième édition la sylviculture les
élèves devaient créer un robot capable
de reconnaître et planter des arbres sur
un circuit uniquement créés pour
l'occasion
il faut savoir que mes élèves ont
travaillé sont venus travailler sur le
projet à peu près trois heures par
semaine sur leur temps libre c'est à
dire après après le repas entre 4 heures
et 14 heures
trois fois par semaine cette semaine
encore certains élèves sont venus à la
fin des cours ou le mercredi après midi
pour finaliser les derniers détails
travailler en équipe ou développer les
connaissances des élèves en informatique
le concours avait surtout une visée
pédagogique certaines vocations se sont
aussi révélés moi j'aimerais bien en
faire mon métier plus tard peut-être et
toi moi ça t'a plu et pourquoi c'était
sympa la programmation je pense que je
vais m'orienter par là dans l'avenir
donc ça permet de découvrir aussi un
petit peu pour la première fois cette
année des élèves en situation de
handicap ont participé au challenge
robotique
fort de son succès une quatrième édition
sera programmée